the more women have been in charge of
their own mate selection the more
Partners we've had so is there something
about women that's actually not
monogamous well no because I think what
you're touching I mean those things are
correlated right so
um that's correlated with the Advent of
reliable methods of artificial
contraceptive uh and even like even when
you haven't started before like the
birth rate started to decline before it
actually like because a lot of people
think it was the 60s but it's actually
been declining since the 1800s and in
1920 like we we do see a dip in the
birth rate and like they they attribute
that to women like living in an
apartment outside like by herself or
before she would go straight from like
her parents house to her husband's house
oh wow so so it's interesting like when
you think about it like it did like
women like then began to have more
Partners sexually so it's like it seems
like when like throughout history like
they've just been trying to like keep
women from like not to be so
you're saying that women should be
allowed to own property
do I actually have never thought about
that question